if you're gonna go looking for a house
make sure it's not Satan's house
distortive advice might keep you alive
as above so below size above so below is
a found footage movie I know what you're
thinking you're like I've seen it all
before and you have seen it all before a
lot of it before but it does have some
really cool elements in it that make you
go oh that's cool doing as above so
below there's this absurdly perfect girl
I swear to god she was like five PhD
speaks five languages and she's you know
twenty-something she's really attractive
they have to do that for a plot
convenient so she's really efficient and
she can get this guy to go with her to
these creepy ass places she's searching
for the philosopher's stone so they make
a plan to go to Hogwarts and knock out
Harry Potter and take that [ __ ] dad are
the gates of hell yeah depending on who
you talk to it's the same name's Harry
Potter's is the devil's books to this
girl and her nomadic kind of boyfriend
love interest isn't really her boyfriend
but you know there's something and a
crew of a few Expendables going to these
catacombs looking for this treasure in
these catacombs of course go deeper and
deeper and deeper and they ultimately
it's kind of like the game genre which
is very very bad for them this movie has
its cliches for sure other than the main
girl and her kind of boyfriend and the
main tour-guide guy wouldn't call him a
tour guide he's their main guide he's
taking them into these catacombs other
than then this movie has a fully
expendable cast is like hey read Star
Trek shirt people start dying the devil
really wants to kill the black guy in
this movie the guy narrowly escapes
death a few times you're like man
Satan's really out for that dude the
cool thing comes when they start seeing
really creepy things there are really
cool visuals in this movie and the sound
is really eerie and that's the key right
there
Eli Roth has this quote I'm not even the
biggest Eli Roth fan to be honest with
you but this quote is so perfect for
horror movies that I got to give a guy
prize I love the quote so much I'm about
to misquote it right here but I
apologize but the quote is something
like if you want to make a horror movie
not scary cover your ears not your eyes
and that's so perfect it is the sound
that makes a horror movie creepy and
this movie has that element in it you
hear kid's cackling you have really
creepy imagery going along with the
sound really cool edits that add effect
again you've seen it in horror movies
before you've seen it and found footage
movies definitely there's something
really claustrophobic and vulnerable
about this movie this movie does a good
job unlike a
a lot of other found-footage movies is
putting you in the first person of these
people who are going through these
catacombs couple times it was the view
of the helmet-cam and I was like I feel
like I'm running from these things right
now and that's really awesome
found-footage movies generally speaking
have a slow build-up this movie is no
exception but this movie does have a leg
up on other found-footage movies in that
department and that is the fact that
while this movie is going through its
slow build-up phase before like the
demons and [ __ ] or chasing them down
before they're hallucinating and seeing
things they're going through catacombs
or solving puzzles and ship there's
booby traps like Goonies and whatnot
when you're going through catacombs and
there are booby traps and their
hieroglyphs on the wall in the reading
it that's a lot cooler than camera
number three in the guest bedroom
showing you something in the closet a
ghost in the closet oh here to scare you
and when the [ __ ] goes down in this
movie this [ __ ] really goes down in this
movie and it was really intense and I
liked the ending I feel like as above so
below was a found footage movie made for
fans of found-footage movies they're
fans of the genre they know what they're
getting into they know they're gonna
watch this movie and see things they've
seen before it has enough cool elements
in it to where they're gonna be like oh
I hadn't actually seen that before so
although this movie does have a slow
startup and predominantly a cast you
don't give a [ __ ] about you're there to
watch them die or suffer or some [ __ ]
you've seen a lot of things in this
movie before I did find enjoyment in the
movie because I liked me some good
horror movies and the found-footage
genre has been pretty stale lately know
what you're getting into when you're
going into this movie if you don't like
found-footage movies at all you're not
gonna like this movie if you're a fan of
the genre but you feel like they've been
lacking lately I'd say give it a try I
will say as above so below is a good
time no alcohol required sighs above so
below have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you